DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Hello,
and welcome to Cloud OnAir,
our live webinars
from Google Cloud that
happen every Tuesday.
Today we are talking
about the future
of databases in the cloud and
my name is Deepti Srivastava.
I am the product manager
for Cloud Spanner.
So let's get started.
So before we talk
about Spanner and why
we think it's the future
of databases and cloud,
I think it's important to go
through a little bit of how
we got here, all of us.
How IT, and databases,
and data itself got here.
So for cloud, it is
still very, very early.
So most of global IT spend, as
you can see here from Gartner,
most of the global IT
spend is still on prem
and very little of it, very
small percentage of it,
is actually in the cloud so far.
So most of cloud growth
is going to happen
in the next 5 to 10 years.
Welcome back.
Apologies for that.
We've fixed the
issue on our side,
so we'll just continue
right where we were.
And we were very early
in our presentation
too, so you haven't
lost anything
if you're just tuning in.
All right.
So we were talking about global
IT spend and how much of it
is really in cloud.
And as you can see
from this chart
that we've got from Gartner
here, from last year's Gartner
reports, very little of
it is still in cloud.
So each of these businesses and
each of these infrastructures
have a database.
You always need
to have a database
to store your critical data
or not so critical data.
So for database spend, it's
extremely early in terms
of clouded option.
So as you can see here, first
of all, most of database spend
is in operational DBMSs
and very little of it
is actually in the
non-relational open source
world.
Despite all the
marketing you hear
from the non-relational
side of the spectrum here,
most data is actually stored
in relational databases.
And that's obvious, right?
Because with relational
databases you get transactions.
You get atomicity of updates.
You get integrity of data.
You get consistency
guarantees, et cetera.
Which are, of course, very,
very useful, as we all know,
for developing applications.
So obviously this implies
that a lot of the databases
out there are
relational and most
of the mission critical
data that a company has
will be stored in
relational databases.
So before we jump into the
growth of relational databases,
it's important to talk about
what we mean by mission
critical.
So when we are talking about
mission critical data, what
we really mean is data
that is business critical.
So loss of that data or even
a glitch in serving that data
affects your reputation and has
financial risk to your company.
So all of this data
that is required
for you to run your
business is what
we call mission
critical data, and we're
saying that most of that mission
critical data is stored in most
cases in relational databases.
So again, where are we at with
the current state of databases?
So most companies, as we talked
about earlier, most of the IT
spend is still on prem.
What that means is that
most databases are still
running on prem.
And most companies
are then managing
their own inflexible
database infrastructure
on premises with
an army of people
trying to maintain
that infrastructure,
and maintain their databases,
and keep them alive
and running.
And of course, there is a
huge overhead in having those.
There are those companies
who have taken the leap
and adopted cloud
to some extent.
And what that means is they
are using infrastructure
as a service from
cloud providers.
So they're running their
own database solutions
on top of these cloud
provider infrastructure.
So they're still in the business
of maintaining, managing,
and administering, and
keeping their databases alive.
They may not need to run
the machines themselves
that host those
databases, but they still
have to deal with the database
maintenance and management.
And then there are companies who
have taken a bigger leap where
they're actually
paying a service
provider to manage
and run their database
solutions in the cloud.
So this means that
they don't have
to worry about actually
keeping the database alive.
There is a service
that's doing that.
But that still
means that they have
to make sure that the
databases are running
the way that's expected.
They have to deal
with the service
provider for their
database service
and maybe deal with other
providers for other services.
So there is some
complication there.
Now apart from where the systems
and the databases are running,
the other limitation is
in technology itself.
So companies are running
into limitations around RDBMS
scale up, and scale out,
and sharding solutions.
So if you run out of capacity of
your database, what do you do?
You have to either scale
up to bigger machines
or you have to go to
the sharded solutions.
Then they come with
their own headaches,
which we'll get into
in a little bit.
And finally, companies are
dealing with the administration
and consistency challenges
of scalable solutions
that are also NoSQL
or non-relational.
So for those
companies who already
hit the problem
with their databases
and the scale of them, and
have adopted more scalable
solutions that are
NoSQL or non-relational,
they're trading off
consistency for scale
or the traditional relational
semantics for scale.
They're running into challenges
of having the consistency
issues and the challenges
in running and administering
these NoSQL solutions, whether
on prem or in the cloud.
The technology
challenges still remain.
So what does that mean
for where we are in terms
of the spectrum of technology?
So we have this very
interesting tradeoff
between traditional
relational databases
and traditional
non-relational databases.
So on the business side,
traditional databases
provide you with schema,
with SQL, with consistency.
And the NoSQL or
non-traditional solutions
don't provide you
those, but they
trade those off for
high availability,
horizontal scalability,
replication, et cetera.
Which is the exact limitations
of traditional relational
databases, in most cases.
What that means is, when you
want to run high availability
relational databases for your
mission critical applications,
you have to create these
highly complex architectures
to provide that availability,
and replication, and disaster
recovery solutions for
your mission critical data.
And, as you can see, you're
running multiple masters,
you're running read
replicas for scaling out
and offloading the read-only
data access, et cetera.
You're trying to have memcache
in there somewhere so that you
can do faster reads
of your data, which
means you have to deal with
the flushing of the cache.
And you have to deal
with consistency issues
with having multiple
masters, if you need that.
You have backup replicas.
So managing this
system, now you've
gone from one database
that hosts your mission
critical data to this
complicated architecture that,
again, requires an
army to maintain.
You don't actually know
where the bottlenecks
are, in some cases, because
the system is so fragile.
And god forbid if one
piece of it somehow fails
and then you have to figure out
what the cascade effects are.
And in most cases,
you don't actually
even know what the
full picture is
because it's become such a
complicated organically grown
beast.
So going back to
first principles,
what do customers want?
What do you want
from your database?
So obviously, you want it to be
highly available and scalable.
And you want it to give
you data consistency
so you can access
data confidently
for your application.
And you can serve the
correct inaccurate data
to your customers.
And of course, from a
developer standpoint,
when you're building and
using these databases,
you want simplified operations.
You want standards.
You want single points
of contact for support.
You don't want to have
to talk to the database
provider, and the infrastructure
manager, and the cloud provider
separately.
You want to have one
person or one contact point
that you can go to if
you have any issues.
So you don't have
to deal with crises
by being the coordinator of
various pieces in that crisis.
Basically you want
your databases
to run while you
can build and grow
your application
and your business.
And this is where
Spanner comes in.
So why do we build Spanner?
And how did we get here?
So if we go back
in time to 2005,
technical
infrastructure at Google
had various scalable
solutions because we'd already
reached the scale versus
consistency problem.
So we had scalable
data storage systems.
But we were lacking
in transactions
and relational semantics
in those systems.
And as we've learned,
as we all know,
those little semantics, SQL,
et cetera, are very important.
And they really help you
run your business well.
So Google reached that point.
And so the need of the hour was
horizontally scaling databases.
We have ACID transactions
and global consistency.
And of course, we are Google,
so we want no downtime.
We want high availability.
We want you to be
able to access Google
from anywhere at all times.
So we came up with Spanner.
We developed Spanner
with a lot of research
and a lot of
understanding of how
to build distributed, scalable,
highly available systems.
And what we have here is the
paper that we published in 2012
that talks about the technology
that we built at the time.
So Spanner was
launched externally
as Cloud Spanner, which is
a publicly available product
on Google Cloud Platform.
And it's about
exactly a year ago
that it was launched
publicly on GCP.
So we're celebrating
our first anniversary
as a cloud database.
So Cloud Spanner is
an enterprise-grade
globally-distributed and
strongly-consistent database
service built
specifically for the cloud
to combine the benefits of our
relational database structure
with non-relational
horizontal scale.
So what does that mean?
We're basically
saying you don't have
to trade off or make compromises
between relational semantics
and horizontal scale, which is
what traditionally companies
and IT folks have had to do.
Database users have had to do.
They've had to basically
trade off and give up
on relational semantics and
build that in the application
to get horizontal scale
to manage their data
growth over the course
of the data exploding
for their business.
So Spanner allows you to not
have to make that compromise.
It's our no compromise
relational database service.
And you get all of this packaged
up in a managed service,
so you can focus on the
application using that database
and not have to worry about
running the database itself.
So we provide schemas,
ACID transactions, SQL,
and the relational scale
with up to five lines
of availability and
an availability SLA,
so we guarantee that.
We're in a fully managed,
easily scalable service.
So if we hark back
to our chart of what
are the pros and
cons of relational
versus traditional
non-relational services
or databases, you don't have
to make those tradeoffs.
We have schemas, we have
SQL, we have consistency,
like traditional
relational databases.
And we have availability,
scale, and replication.
And, by the way, a bunch of
it out of the box that you
can get with non-relational
traditional NoSQL systems.
So again, you don't
have to make compromises
between technical needs
and business needs
in order to really
run your applications
and your business critical data.
Now there are differences
in the technology of Spanner
and traditional
relational databases
and how they've worked so far.
And of course, there
is innovation here
that allows us to do this
relational with scale.
And I can touch upon
a little bit of that.
But the important
thing to note here is,
like traditional databases,
you get tables, you get DDL,
you get the same schemas
that you're used to.
So you do create table, you
have primary keys, et cetera.
And in this picture,
you can see that we've
created two different tables
which have relationships
that you can see.
And you use simple
DDL statements
in order to create this table.
And you'll use this schema
change DDL statements as well
to alter table or drop
column, et cetera, as well.
So again, these are
the familiar constructs
that you're used to so far
with traditional relational
that you get with Spanner as
well with some added benefits.
So in this case, you
see these two tables.
And if we were to see how this
logical structure is laid out,
Spanner has a concept
of interleaving.
It's one of the many
technical differences,
but it's interesting
to point out
as it showcases how
we've been built
for scale with the relational
transactional semantics.
So in the previous case, we
had two different tables.
And they're logically different.
There's the albums table
and the singers table.
But if you interleave the albums
table and the singers table,
what that means is that the
data is logically co-located.
So you essentially can
think of it as a pre-join.
So when you're doing large
data set reads or scans,
you don't have to actually
do the join at a run time.
You can predetermine
that these data sets are
going to be queried together
and you can logically
tell the system to store
them together so that they
can be retrieved much faster.
For a few MBs or
a few GBs of data,
joining may not be a
latency causing issue.
But when you have hundreds
of gigabytes or hundreds
of terabytes of
data and you need
to do all albums for
all singers, a query,
that's a lot of data to
be joined and processed
at runtime, at query time.
So instead of having to
do a join at that time,
you can specify to
this system that you
need to pre-join this
data set because your most
common queries are actually
going to scan the singers along
with their albums.
So in this case, the system
can very quickly read the data
and return the query
results without having
to do the computationally
intensive join,
hence reducing read time
or query serving time.
Again, you can use interleaving
for indexes as well.
So we have secondary indexes.
We are a relational database.
And from that standpoint,
you can, of course,
have separate logical
indexes, which
can be standard tables in
other traditional databases.
And in our case, they are
standard tables as well,
but you can interleave them.
So again, if you're going
to have to back join indexes
with the base table because your
most common query is requiring
that pattern, then you
can interleave the indexes
within the base table.
And again, that can lead to
much faster selects and queries
of your data.
So this is just one of the ways
in which Spanner is different.
But it shows you
under the covers
the technological
differences we have,
which allows us to provide
scale with relational semantics.
So, as Nick says in
this quote from Gartner,
when we launched
Spanner, and we talked
about it with various
analysts, and of course we
have customers
that are using it,
it's interesting
because it's not just
another take on a
traditional database.
It's really a new
way of thinking,
a new need that's being met by
the technologies at Spanner.
But Spanner is
not just software.
It's the combination of a lot
of very clever software, which
there is a lot of, along
with hardware that we built
specifically for scale and then
to provide the kinds of things
that we need for a large,
highly available, scalable
system, such as atomic
clocks that we have in-house.
TrueTime is a technology we
use for global synchronization
and external consistency.
Which is stronger
than linearizability.
So we use TrueTime, which is
based on atomic clocks and GPS,
to do this coordination.
And that powers
Cloud Spanner as well
and allows it to have that
global external consistency,
which allows us to
then have globally
consistent and strong
relational semantics
database in Cloud Spanner.
And this is, of course, built
on top of our Google network,
which we've talked
about quite a bunch.
And there is a lot
of white papers
and we've actually put
online as well that one
can read if interested.
But basically,
it's a combination
of our Google
networking, which is
highly redundant and
optimized on all levels,
from the network fabric all
the way to the switches,
to the hubs, et cetera.
And atomic clocks and
GPS with TrueTime,
as well as clever software
in Cloud Spanner itself.
So we, for example, have
wrote our own implementation
of Paxos.
We don't use open source
Paxos implementation.
We optimized the Paxos
algorithm in our implementation
for our specific use case.
Which allows us to, again,
do low latency transactions
and to do strong reads
across continents
and across oceanic links.
And all of this combines
to give you Cloud Spanner.
So there's a bunch of customers
that are using Spanner
and they're excited about it.
And I am personally excited
to talk about a few of them
that I've been seeing them win.
And it's really
exciting for us to see
how the world has adopted
and started to use Spanner.
So it's not just
about trading off
CapEx for OpEx, which is what a
managed database service gives
you.
That's kind of the
promise of cloud.
But with cloud,
customers are trying
to do inherently new
and exciting things
that they couldn't do
before because they
were limited by technology.
And in this case, Optiva, which
is a telecom communications
billing and charging system, as
mission critical as they get,
it has adopted Spanner as its
next generation database system
for its next
generations of software
for billing and charging.
And when they looked
at Spanner, they
saw improved performance and
reliability from their existing
traditional architectures.
And they actually saw 10
times more throughput,
so 10 times more
transactions per second,
at a dramatically reduced cost.
So Optiva was actually
presenting this week
at Mobile World
Congress in Barcelona.
And I'm here with you
and I'm not there.
But it's really exciting
because they're really
excited about the technology.
They're really excited
about the possibilities
it opens up for them
and for their customers.
And that's really the reason to
have Cloud Spanner as a managed
database service.
They don't have to worry
about the system itself.
And also, because
of its combination
of relational semantics
and horizontal scale,
they can do things
with this technology
that they couldn't do with their
existing on prem solutions.
So another interesting example,
one of my favorites actually,
Marketo and the one
following, is again,
Marketo is a marketing
platform that
provides marketing
applications for companies
all over the world.
And for them, in
their own words,
having order sequence in
their application logic
is very important.
And, as they were looking
to go to cloud and looking,
obviously, the first step is,
which cloud provider do I use?
And the second
question for most of us
is, what database services do
each of these cloud providers
have?
And how do I use them?
Is it easier for me
to use these services
or is it going to make
my life more difficult?
And the Cloud
Spanner, again, they
could use the system
to have the order,
and sequence guarantees,
and the app logic,
so they didn't have to
write brittle application
logic to have that sequencing.
With NoSQL and with
systems that are scaled,
but lacking in
transactional consistency
or strong consistency,
all of that
has to be built into the app.
Which means your application
becomes a lot more complicated
and your team is
basically stressing
in keeping that system
alive and running
instead of building cool
things to serve your customers.
And that obviously is a
productivity hit, but also
a growth hit for you.
It affects your
business bottom line.
And in this case,
when you don't have
to worry about that anymore,
you can choose Spanner.
You don't have to re-platform
or think of re-platforming ever.
You just grow as your
global business grows.
That's a powerful statement.
And another one of our
favorite customers, Evernote,
I think a lot of
people know Evernote.
Again, they had a multiple
hundred shard SQL system.
They want their users' notes
to be obviously available,
no matter where they are.
And they.
With Cloud Spanner,
can go to a system that
reduces this complexity,
gives them scale.
And once they have
migrated, they
don't actually have to think
about the re-platforming
ever again.
So it reduces, in fact,
eliminates, all of that
stress of managing the
complicated multi-shard mySQL
system that keeps their
operations team awake at night.
From that to building
more functionality
and having ease of use of their
application and infrastructure.
So we talked about the positive
things in Cloud Spanner
or how it's different from
traditional relational
non-relational databases.
But it's important to note
that Google Cloud platform's
database portfolio is vast.
And Spanner is one piece of it.
We actually have memcache all
the way on the left to our data
warehouse in the
cloud with BigQuery.
So the way I think about
Cloud Spanner and BigQuery
is, if you're used to
traditional relational
databases and data warehouses,
Cloud Spanner and BigQuery are
the cloud equivalents of those.
But Cloud Spanner is
deliberately placed
next to non-relational
systems in this chart
because it allows you to
have non-relational scale,
along with the relational
semantics that it offers.
So the whole portfolio allows
you to have a bunch of tools
that you can choose from to
build the kinds of systems
you need for your application.
We're not trying to tie you down
to one and only one solution,
but we're not giving
you 100s to choose from.
We think there are
different use cases that
require very specific,
tailored solutions for storage.
And with this portfolio
we basically offer
you a solution for each of
those specific use cases.
What that also
means is, again, you
have the toolkit to
choose the right system.
But you're not left on
your own to figure out
which system you need to use
among hundreds or dozens.
There is, as I said, a solution
for each specific use case
and we hope you choose the
right system for the use case.
So as this chart shows,
there is a flow chart
that you can use to
pick the system you
want for the use case you have.
And this is, again, up
on our docs in cloud,
so you can look it
up there as well,
along with a lot
more information.
So hopefully that
gave you an overview
of why we think of Cloud Spanner
as the future of database
systems.
And we'll take a short
break of less than a minute
and come back for a live Q&A
section as well, so stay tuned.
Welcome back to Cloud OnAir.
Let's get straight to
our audience questions
for the day from this webinar.
So question 1, are you expecting
all relational databases
to migrate to cloud immediately?
Absolutely not.
There are many reasons
why most of the IT
spend is still on prem
and not in the cloud.
As I had mentioned
earlier in my talk,
we know that these are
early days of cloud.
But what we want to make sure
is that customers understand
that they don't need to shy
away from adopting cloud
because they think
they can't get
the performance or the
semantics that they're
expecting from their
applications in the cloud.
And if you're needing horizontal
scale and relational semantics,
for example, you
don't have to worry
about not being able
to do that in the cloud
because, for example,
we have Cloud Spanner
on Google Cloud that will
allow you to have that
without compromises.
So we expect most of
the cloud migration
to happen in the next three
to five years and beyond.
There are many reasons for
not being in the cloud right
now, as I said.
You've already made
commitments, you've already
bought the machines, you've
already got data center space,
you've already got colo space
for your data infrastructure.
So it'll take time.
But I know that a
lot of companies
are looking at
migrating to the cloud
and it's important that they
see the full picture and all
the options available to
them so that they don't have
to shy away from
it for, let's say,
performance, or manageability,
or any of those reasons.
So moving on.
Why not just use a
non-relational database
on prem or in the cloud?
So I think I touched
upon that earlier.
If you want to use a
non-relational database,
that's totally up to you.
However, non-relational
databases
come with the complexity
that we talked about.
If you need
relational semantics,
and most mission critical
data does, like bank systems,
telco systems,
health care systems.
When you need
relational semantics
and you're trying to use a
non-relational database, what
that means is you've given up
on transaction of the system,
you've given up on
strong consistency,
you've given on structured
data, you've given up on SQL.
SQL-like is not the
same as SQL, right?
Anybody who's used
a SQL-like system
can know that it's not SQL.
So you've given
up on all of those
to get the scale with these
non-relational databases.
And if that works
for you, great.
But it does mean that if
you need those things,
you have to build them
in the application.
And anybody who's even
attempted to build them
knows that this is
super complicated code.
It's got so many
edge cases that you
have to think about
and take care of.
It's brittle because actually
rolling your own transaction
in the application
layer is hard.
[INAUDIBLE] in the sharded
solution, for example.
Doing the logic to
join between two shards
and all those kinds of
things are really hard.
And again, if you like
doing that kind of stuff,
that's great.
But for most people,
they're trying
to just build their applications
to run their businesses.
And they don't want to
worry about these things.
And in that case,
non-relational databases
just don't cut it
for what they need.
What's the difference between
Cloud Spanner and BigQuery?
Can't I just use BigQuery?
So it's basically the difference
between OLTP and OLAP systems.
So are you looking for an
enterprise data warehouse
or are you looking for
a operational mission
critical database?
That is literally when you
would choose one or the other.
Cloud Spanner for OLTP
systems and BigQuery
for OLAP systems or
enterprise data warehouse.
So if I were to think about
it in the on-prem world
or in the traditional
world, it would
be the difference between
Oracle or SQL Server and Netezza
or Teradata.
That's the real difference.
And in fact, we are
basically trying
to make it simple for customers
to use their operational data
in a data warehouse with
Cloud Spanner or BigQuery
so you don't have to
have complicated tools
for ETLing data out of
your relational database,
out of your
operational database,
and moving it to
your data warehouse.
There are simple
tools that we are
working on that will allow
you to quickly transfer data
from Cloud Spanner
into BigQuery.
And then over time
that you don't even
have to do the ETL at all.
It can be as simple as
a push button thing.
Moving on.
Does Cloud Spanner
have every feature
that traditional databases do?
No.
It's a different
take on the system.
So there are specific
features that Cloud Spanner
doesn't have now that we're
working on to fill those gaps.
Like DML, obviously, and
backups, and things like that.
And triggers and queues.
These are all part
of our roadmap.
I would hope that our
audience and our customers
give us some time.
Because we just launched last
year and traditional databases
have been around
for 30, 40 years.
So we're trying and
moving very fast.
And we're going to close those
relational database feature
gaps that are critical.
There's certain
things that are not
critical for relational
databases that
somehow are supposed to be.
Stored procedures, for example.
That's just a way of pushing
down application logic
into the database layer.
Which we don't actually
think that's the way
we want to go with our system.
We want to have a lean,
mean database that
can do the things you need
it to do, which is you
strong consistency
transaction, et cetera.
And we want to give this
to you in global scale.
But we think that application
developers know best how
to write their applications.
And that's the way we want
to offer this service.
So we the Cloud Spanner, we're
the new take on databases.
We were able to go back
to first principles
and think about
why databases exist
and what they're needed
for, what they're used.
And we were able to cut
out all the flack, cruft
that's been building up
in databases for a while.
And we were able to go back to
first principles for databases
and then provide the features
and functionality that
are truly core for
databases, especially
relational databases.
And as I said, yes, it doesn't
have every feature right now
which we're going to fill.
But it also has features that
no other relational database,
or in fact, no
other database has.
Which is global, strong
consistency, replication out
of the box, transparent,
securities built in,
and transparent, et cetera.
Next question.
Why is sharding a
database so difficult?
So if you ever had
to shard a database,
this would an obvious
answer really.
So think about a database
with a bunch of tables.
And now think about the
fact that you can't actually
buy a big enough box to hold all
that data in all those tables.
So what you have to do then is,
and I'm going to simplify here.
There are many things that
go into consideration here.
But at the simplest
level, what you have to do
is basically take the table,
if you have 10 tables,
take each table and then put
it in a different database.
Because that way
at least the data
set for that table
is going to fit
in your traditional
single box machine.
So you have 10 tables across
10 different databases.
So of course, you can just
keep using your tooling
and you can keep
using transactions
all for within that table
or maybe two tables.
With a table and
index, let's say.
But it behaves exactly the same
as one database for that one
table and its one index.
But if you ever had to do
anything across those tables,
then you have to write
the transaction logic
in the application
to do the join
and to do the
transactions on them.
So you essentially will
have to write the protocol
to commit a transaction
that is done
in a database inside
the application layer
without having the engine
that runs the system.
The database engine is what runs
these transactions, et cetera,
and does the consistency
and guarantees, et cetera.
So to do that in the application
layer is extremely hard
and, as I said, very brittle.
If you're doing a two-phase
commit, for example,
what happens if one
shard is unavailable,
but the other shard committed?
So do you roll back
that shard, or do you
retry on the first shard?
And what happens if,
during the commit,
there was a network outage?
So do you know whether the
transaction committed or not?
How do you recover from
that state, et cetera?
So there's many,
many things that
go into making sharded
database work well.
And all of them make the
application developers' life
very hard.
So those are some of
the questions we had.
I don't think we have
any more questions,
so I think we'll call it a day.
And thank you,
again, for watching
and for tuning into
our live webinar.
As I said, we have
these live webinars
for Cloud OnAir every Tuesday.
So please log in next Tuesday
for our upcoming webinars
on collaboration and
productivity tools,
as well as machine learning,
among other topics.
Thank you so much.
Have a great day.